mise à dos miss france miss france 1987
plus est mais pourquoi donc
retour quelques jours avant l'une
d'elles sera élue miss france dans
quelques jours elles sont venues de 38
régions décembre 1986 c'est une grande
première
l'élection de miss france sera diffusé
pour la première fois à la télévision et
en direct pour assurer le show
guy lux et une idée c'est la première
fois que les téléspectateurs aussi
seront amenés à élire miss france miss
france 1987
oui je crois que c'est la première
comment ça va se passer l'année fait sa
40e les 48 47 80 euros mis du temps les
téléspectateurs vont donner leurs amis
31 décembre 1986 c'est parti et surprise
de la soirée ce sera bien sûr et pour la
première fois sur une chaîne de
télévision française
l'élection de miss france les miss
défilent et se présente âge profession
signe astrologique et le public vote en
appelant europe 1 partenaire de
l'événement un partenaire qui s'y perd
entre classement et dauphine et là c'est
le drame
la troisième dauphine c'est cette visite
n attendais parce que là on a renversé
de fait une petite erreur au final une
mise quitte le plateau
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce que la
nôtre bis elle se fâche tabac une miss
proteste elle dit que pourtant pour la
première fois c'est le public qui vote
et personne d'autre après dix minutes de
cafouillages en direct nathalie marquay
19 ans est élue miss france
cette première élection télévisée a été
une catastrophe
vous savez qu'elle a été lu dans des
conditions un peu difficiles la nuit de
la saint sylvestre a pas dit mais malgré
cette première chaotique
chaque année l'élection de miss france
est en direct avec le vote du public
le show est aujourd'hui bien rodée et
rassemble des millions de
téléspectateurs
pas moins de sept millions en décembre
[Musique]